here's the peek at what guests had to
say after the show okay so the
Washington Redskins changed their name
as our first question yes Sarah
Silverman says alone yes everybody says
you know there's a linguist at
Smithsonian named Ives Goddard who
looked at the history of the term and
concluded a guy with real credentials
I'm not an expert but he said that this
was actually a phrase and an expression
that Native Americans we didn't call
them that then coined for themselves I
think that the history is not as clear
as people complaining today make it out
to be what the picture and the crazy guy
with the hatchet the feather yeah he's
going to scalp somebody but but who
cares if it's but if they don't like it
I mean if they haven't done enough [ __ ]
to the Indians we can't give this little
I mean we [ __ ] committed genocide
getting smallpox took their land we
can't even just change the name of a
team in one year they would completely
forget it smoked in bars and restaurants
wouldn't imagine life without that right
right I think the real Americans deserve
the name that they want I do want it out
route that's what
[Applause]
does Nancy Pelosi appointing Democrats
that a Benghazi investigative panel give
the scandal of validity now this was a
hard one for the Democrats they wanted
on the one hand to boycott this because
it's a community [ __ ] panel on the
other hand they wanted somebody on the
panel to be able to at least make the
counter-argument when the crazy stuff
was voiced did they do the right thing
you know here's here's the here's the
Libya question that gets lost in in the
Benghazi uproar which is went to war in
Libya to overthrow Gaddafi and Libya now
is more unstable more unpredictable
because the the prep this president
following his some of his predecessors
that I'm prepared to go to war but I'm
not prepared to do what is necessary to
make the success of the war and that and
I think is what the country is
struggling the Benghazi story struggling
to put its hands on is why is Al Qaeda
in any may be a now okay we didn't
really go to war at the moment it was a
humanitarian crisis they thought that
Qaddafi who was still alive as you
recall they thought his troops were
going to be slaughtering people so they
bombed from the air it cost a billion
dollars we've lose that in the couch
every day at the Pentagon we we didn't
exactly go to war we deploy it so poor
we did it with airplanes but the and we
did it with covert means and we provided
it we've provided weapons and trainers
were against that you were for I thought
I was worth that I was four I was for
Libya okay but but wait I assumed was
going to happen was there was going to
be afterwards a stage for operation a
phase for operation and they were going
to make it a better place
what would I doing what buy it by that's
on the ground replaced by providing it
you don't need a lot of soldiers but you
need a lot of other kind you need some
soldiers you need some kind of sit away
you probably putting more boots on the
ground in another Muslim well if you're
not prepared to do that then leave
Qaddafi alone because you don't have a
plan for what comes next
Colin power so you would raise allowed
him to slaughter people no I know I as I
said I I was in favor of that
intervention but I would have expected
it to be seen all the way through
instead of to say okay he's gone goodbye
and what happens now
we don't care this country that is on
the north shore of the Mediterranean
what 200 miles from the coast of 300
miles and coast of Italy can I make a
quick point I don't buy into all of
these Benghazi hearings the one that I'd
like to hear is the investigation as to
why we haven't brought to justice
whoever killed the four Americans and
that's not what this is about Benghazi
has become if you remember from Seinfeld
Festivus the the airing the airing of
all grievances it's this like one-word
catchphrase for everything that this
evildoer the president according to them
has ever done it's been a moving target
from Jump Street and this is just a
continuation of that isn't it time for
the major sports leagues to rethink
their policies on marijuana use by
athletes yes I mean so many of the
athletes smoke weed and and so many of
them do it because they're in constant
pain from the sport that they play and
somebody them do it just because they're
loyal people Americans like me they
would be far better off smoking pot than
they would getting hooked on
prescription pain meds right which then
has Williams from the Dolphins oh
there's the the great running back he
want he was a big pot smoker they
suspended him over and over again and he
was like you know what I have these
anxiety issues marijuana helps me and
they were like no you're gonna use this
stuff from Pfizer and Eli Lilly just
like a real man would I may be the I may
be the last person standing opposing
legalization but those interested I
wrote a big article with a lot of sites
in the last issue of commentary
explaining why this is a public policy
disaster in the making don't do it just
the money that will go to the deficit to
statewide alone but it's it's so much
better for you than people die every day
drunk drinking have you ever heard of
the dying from pot and driving we smoked
a lot of weed do we strike you as crazy
you know I get put on spot the spot that
way a lot and I don't know the correct
answer is well but let's put this with
tobacco and alcohol are both dwindling
problems fewer and fewer Americans drink
fewer fewer Americans read the article
and look at the site sales are coming
back that's they never went away I when
I was really big cocktail ring West
American strength West the alcohol
consumption is down maybe a little
dramatically downs down to one in a five
whatever legal don't have drug problem
yes when I was in high school I was the
delivery boy for the local liquor store
and I learned something about liquor
it's a fantastic product to sell because
people love it when they're happy and
celebrating and they need it when
they're down and depressed right it's
always in vogue and it will always be
invoked because liquor always works
that's the thing about liquor other
drugs like the more you do them the more
they wear off I hear by November will
the ACA Obamacare encourage more people
to vote for Republicans or Democrats ooh
good question I think it's gonna turn
around I do think it's gonna you know I
don't know by November but it's one of
those issues more it's gonna be real for
more and more people it was in the paper
this week we have the lowest number of
people ever in this country uninsured
thirteen point four million another
example of Obama everybody screaming
about him he just quietly goes about his
business and when the when the you know
when the history books are written
I think he's gonna look pretty good
I agree with you that if it turns but
not by this November I mean I don't know
if in a my views are ten years we look
back and we say my god can you believe
the polls that existed in 2014 the
reason it doesn't turn this cycle
nobody's going to be out there banging
the drum in support of it beyond the
president and he doesn't have the heft
I don't think the Democrats are gonna
fight the fight that they probably
should yeah right right we're gonna be
spending a generation debugging this
thing but it was passed it was passed
but we did that with other programs yeah
but this what the problem the financing
mechanism doesn't work the reliance on
Medicaid is an enormous problem the
wreck the regulatory measures are
burdensome I hope that we do spend the
rest of many years making it honing it
just right why wouldn't why do things
have to be perfect immediately mandate
and nothing is long-term this is going
to be this is going to be long-term the
way the Hundred Years War was long-term
well I have to say by the way as
somebody here who doesn't even have
health insurance because undocumented
people can't help watching all these
Americans debate like the health care
I'm like wait a second like I paid my
taxes I'm from here and they won't give
us health insurance and I mean I got I
had to go to the ER a few months ago
here in LA actually I'd have to go to
the ER and pay my way and you know hear
all the time about how endowment will
are crowding your emergency rooms and
where are the ones costing you know
we're not we're the ones keeping Social
Security solvent is what we're doing
right we're the one working harder than
what you could possibly even realize
undocumented people in California alone
2.6 billion dollars in state taxes in
2010 you never hear that Wow let's hear
it for the Filipinos
real time would go more ask villainous
guests your questions right after the
show at hbo.com or on Twitter